how's it go Russ don't make up with me
today we're gonna make cartoon
characters come to real life with a
magic of Photoshop so I thought this
could be a new fun series first episode
you bros suggested there sim sense
ah-yi it's gonna get we what if the
Simpson characters were real
let's explore let's start with Homer I
feel like this is a good base I'm all
about that bass about that but up let's
do the nose first he doesn't really have
nostrils does he
well that's a good start
his ear is a little smaller looks pretty
legit so far I would say now the ice
like this might be a problem I mean yeah
that looks that looks great so good
dammit how I how I this'll how much on
his pupils are still tiny though so
we're gonna have to fix that all right
that looks terrifying that's great
terrifying and slightly turning you on
that's that's what I want that's what
I'm going for
this is not what if cartoons were real
this is what if demons were real damn it
all right then
oh my [ __ ] Simpson baby that's
what I'm talking about let's do some
tiny little bit of detail work that
looks great
you look good I'm so proud of you you
look good all right let's do the
coloring you gotta look good baby
and the beard and of course the hair all
right I think I think we nailed it man I
think it needs to be a little fatter
actually there you have it ladies and
brothers before Homer Simpson after
either I think it works I think yeah I'm
happy with it
what are you bursting beautiful Lisa
Simpson would be pretty [ __ ] amazing
all right this is gonna look weird
oh this is perfect that's the same dress
and everything Lisa it's your birthday
happy birthday Lou
okay here we go new picture all right
let's fix it here
yep that's how here just look like
nailed that next up eyebrows be gone
okay
eyebrows gone what's Nick the nose the
nose
oh my god this looks terrifying what
happened
[ __ ] happen
I like it I like it a lot okay looks
looks great looks so good I like I don't
even know holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
that
oh my god I've seen deaf now why every
time oh my god
alright take it back now I've seen death
goddamn it's hot all right we all know
that and I know Lisa without the star
haircut over the [ __ ] it is so let's get
that done
oh great I created a monster
all right I have nightmares this is a
terrible idea I take it all back
all right let's make this [ __ ] yellow
hello yellow how sorry I have a problem
that was Lisa Simpson everyone yeah I I
don't know what to say I don't wanna
close my eyes so before release our
simplified FDA Lisa seems to fade hey
Willie shake ok this should be very
interesting to see all right first of
all the years
looks pretty good
no eyebrows stupid eyebrows get away
eyebrows get away from here who do you
think you are
alright that looks yeah sure sure
knows all right
there we go that looks Daleks yes it
looks like an alien seriously okay now
for the eyes my expectations aren't the
highest on this money
look so anymore oh sorry every time okay
let's yeah let's finish up with what we
came for
I mean it is kind of like appealing to
the eye to look at that's how hot it is
he is wearing a red shirt also damn it
there you go 100% Wow all right let's go
through our work of art today we had
Lisa which is probably my favorite then
we had Hamish same scene yeah looking
good and finally there it seems Wow
so Bruce if you enjoyed this I think
it's pretty cool it's fun idea let me
know what else do you want me to see
come to life maybe some anime [ __ ] how
about that I'd be cool anyway thank you
boys for watching and as always leaving
unlike stay awesome bros I mean now
let's be natural it's all about looking
natural natural let's get a little rid
of that stubble
yah-tchi yah-tchi yah-tchi disgusting